et pour en parler nous recevons sur ce
plateau bérenger cernon syndicaliste cgt
cheminots bérenger sert non bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors après le 49-3 on le
disait une nouvelle mobilisation
aujourd'hui la caisse qui va s'exprimer
dans la rue il va s'exprimer beaucoup de
colère et de et de dégoût parce que
c'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement utilise le 49-3 de cette
sorte
c'est à dire que l'on cesse a déjà été
utilisée par par les gouvernements
précédents mais là on est plus dans un
gouvernement qui a une faible majorité
ou du moins qui doutent de sa majorité
on a un gouvernement qui a décidé de
bâillonner l'opposition et qui a décidé
de clore tout débat dans un moment
compliqué pour eux après sept jours de
débats c'est assez explosif 1 où il l'a
vu il ya eu beaucoup de tension au sein
de l'hémicycle et on allait aborder des
questions centrales de ce projet avec
notamment la question de l'âge pivot la
question du financement
la question voilà deux du devenir et
notamment de la valeur du point
donc voilà tous ces sujets là on savait
pertinemment que c'était des sujets
sensibles et qui risquait de faire
exploser la majorité et je pense que
monsieur edouard philippe l'a bien
compris et puis faire une telle annonce
deux heures après avoir annoncé que les
rassemblements de plus de cinq mille
personnes dans des lieux confinés et on
va dire en prime et tour au
rassemblement était étaient proscrits ça
pose vraiment question sur dans quel
état d'esprit et ce gouvernement et
veut-il vraiment aller au clash aller au
conflit
parce que c'est ce qu'il est en train de
faire alors dans la rue pour exprimer
une colère contre le 49-3 vous venez de
le dire mais aussi demander le retrait
pur et simple du projet de la réforme ou
de nouveaux débats bien sûr on demande
le retrait depuis le début ça a été
clair nous on l'a dit le système actuel
qui est c'est un système de par
répartition est le meilleur du monde
voilà c'est le plus probable protecteur
envers les retraités et nous ce qu'on
demande c'est que ce système soit
pérennisée et soit améliorée
malheureusement le gouvernement a décidé
une toute autre réforme une réforme qui
n'est pas financé une réforme qui depuis
le début n'est pas du tout universel et
voilà c'est un passage en force
on l'a vu la majorité l'opinion publique
est contre cette réforme
demande le retrait de cette réforme
malheureusement gouvernement n'en a que
faire et voilà passe en force en plus de
2 voilà deux de passer en force au
niveau de la démocratie au niveau de la
vie de sa population
voilà elle utilise le couperet le 49-3
qui coupent tout débat toute discussion
cette pression sur les gouvernements est
ce que vous avez les moyens de la
maintenir dans le temps aujourd'hui on
va essayer voilà aujourd'hui journée
d'action 13h30 place de la république
mais partout aussi en province et bien
évidemment on va continuer de maintenir
cette pression
il ya eu deux mois de conflit une grève
historique un mouvement très dur
notamment dans les secteurs dans le
secteur des transports
mais dans bien d'autres secteurs aussi
oui ça pèse dans les porte-monnaie et
aujourd'hui on peut plus faire deux mois
de grève comme il ya eu il ya quelques
semaines mais pourtant la mobilisation
elle va être là on va essayer de
l'amplifier parce que aujourd'hui c'est
bien tous les secteurs qui sont
concernés c'est pas uniquement une
question de service public c'est pas une
question de fonctionnaires c'est pas une
question n'en sais vraiment l'ensemble
de la population qui est concerné et oui
la pression de la rue va continuer parce
qu'on le sait on à l'histoire qui va
aussi nous aider un notamment la
question du cpe ou en 2006 malgré le
vote de la loi est bien la pression de
la rue a fait en sorte que ce cette loi
ne soit jamais appliquée eh bien nous
c'est ce qu'on va porter dans la rue et
c'est ce qu'on va continuer à porter
dans les jours à venir
avec on l'espère un gouvernement qui va
finir par prendre conscience que ce
projet doit on n'en veut pas ce projet
de société qui va transformer
complètement un système de retraite qui
l'héritage du conseil national de la
résistance
voilà c'est pas possible de tout balayer
d'un revers de la main et en plus en
coupant tout débat démocratique
alors deux motions de censure également
étudié cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale le député la france soumise
françois ruffin par le lui
dans une motion de censure c'est du
bidon je le cite
est ce qu'il n'ya plus rien à attendre
de l'assemblée nationale sur ce dossier
je pense clairement que aujourd'hui
l'assemblée nationale
malheureusement est rempli de deux
députés qui qui votent
voilà comme un seul homme parce qu'on a
dit on leur a dit de voter on l'a vu un
ce soit sur le congé lorsque on avait un
enfant qui est décédé
on le voit là sur les retraites voilà
aujourd'hui malheureusement l'assemblée
nationale n'a plus ne fait plus office
de débat démocratique ou peut y avoir
des discussions vives c'est pas la
question
malheureusement aujourd'hui ces
discussions vives tourne plus autour de
l' insultes que vraiment sur un vrai
débat de fond parce que des questions de
fond il y en a eu
il n'y a pas eu de réponse est la seule
réponse voilà qu'il ya eu de la part de
ce gouvernement c'est de sortir 1 49 3 1
samedi alors que les présidents de
groupe n'était même pas présent alors
qu'il ya eu un conseil des ministres
extraordinaire où le secrétaire d'état
rapporteur de la loi sur les retraites
n'était même pas présent à ce conseil
des ministres 1
voilà on voit que c'est un profond avec
faiblesse mais en attendant il passe en
force et ça ça passe ça passe très mal
et je pense que ça fait beaucoup de mal
à la démocratie ce qui est en train de
se passer
alors pour conclure une question sur la
conférence de financement france aux
vielles aux français fo force ouvrière
pardon l'a quitté hier la cgt menacent
également de quitter cette conférence
créée à l'origine par la cfdt
qu'est ce qui vous gêne qu'est ce qui
gêne les syndicats mais à partir du
moment où les discussions autour de
cette question du financement est
complètement et où on nous
explique heureusement ne veut pas
baisser les pensions mais de l'autre
côté on ne veut pas non plus augmenter
les cotisations sociales entre
guillemets vous n'avez plus de choix
c'est savoir où mettre le curseur sur
l'âge pivot ou alors carrément cassé les
35 heures et travailler plus donc
forcément à partir de ce moment où il
n'y a plus que ces deux choix là qui
sont disponibles mais les discussions
tournent en rond et clairement il peut
pas il peut être pas y avoir de points
d'accord donc oui forcément au bout d'un
moment quand chacun donné sa position et
qu'on voit que
que chacun reste entre guy marc boutet
sur les siennes bon bah y'a plus
discussions avoir autant autant partir
merci beaucoup bérenger cernon d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle que
vous êtes syndicaliste cgt cheminots